isn't there some tension in
and i know you you talk a lot about this
empathy uh and having empathy and
looking at people as
a human being and as leaders
but they're also being a tension with
that
will to succeed yeah and that drive and
how do you think you best balance that
because i think one without the other
um
you can have an enormously wonderful
culture that isn't actually advancing
the ball the tension is healthy the
tension is good um
you know if all you have is empathy then
you have a hippie commune and you're not
actually going to cure anything
but if all you're doing is driving the
numbers driving the numbers uh you're
gonna have a short life span and break
the machine also and you might have a
spike and then you'll disappear um uh or
all your best people say i i hate it
here and they go work somewhere else and
take all of their their their brilliance
somewhere else um
so you there is a balance but there's
also a hierarchy you know it's not 50
50.
there's no such thing as 50 50. it
doesn't exist you can't say we're 50
driven by performance and 50 driven by
culture because you will face decisions
where one of those things
has to sac
will sacrifice the other now which one
the question is which one are you going
to choose there has to be a bias towards
people
there has to be a bias towards
the teamwork the environment um and the
will to to to succeed is driven by the
belief in the cause um uh uh you know if
if if if the cause is clear and the
metrics and you're letting people see
the metrics so they feel they feel like
we're making progress again go back to
that marathon analogy right which is
you're exhausted you're tired but you're
getting close to the finish line you
start running faster not slower that's a
good point um uh and so uh it's it's
it's keeping people included to know
what the metrics mean
and um and which ones are trending and
which ones are absolute but yeah there's
nothing wrong with the drive to succeed
as long as there's a context within
which within which that drive exists